- Figure out who you are.
Don't apologize for who you
are and then become even greater
than you naturally
are at what you are.
("Unstoppable" by This Is Wolff)
("Doubt It" by Kyle)
My inbox, that form on my
website that goes to De Simone,
the biggest thing that I want
from this salesperson is not to
do new business for
VaynerMedia the way you
and I think about it.
It's to turn the 400 to 900
requests a week we get
that really want
some version of me.
They don't even know
what they want into something.
It's time to create a CRM of
everybody who asked me for
something, convert them
into something for myself,
VaynerMedia or the Vayner family
of millions of characters and
then create data.
I love it.
Well, listen I'm gonna talk to
my brother and see if we can see
if we can figure
something out that's cool,
fun, interesting and
worthwhile for everybody.
- [Man] Awesome, Gary.
Thank you so much.
- My pleasure have
a great day, my man.
Bye-bye. I will.
Keep at it.
I will.
There's one fucking
thing I can guarantee.
Everybody right now,
let's go Jets.
Jets hat.
That I'm gonna
keep fucking at it.
We close?
- [Avi] Block away.
- Bam.
Nice to meet you man.
You too, bro.
Where am I goin'?
- [Man 2] Eight.
- Eight.
Hello, how are you?
- [Woman] Good. How are you?
- [Gary] Good.
I'm Gary Vaynerchuk.
- [Alyson] Gary?
- [Gary] Yep.
How have you been?
- [Alyson] I've been great.
Have you ever
been to our office?
- [Gary] Mhmmm.
I have. I have.
How's the podcast been going?
- [Alyson] Good.
(inaudible)
- [Gary] How many
have you done so far?
- [Alyson] I've done
five or six and I've got,
I think I've got six
more crammed in next week.
So we're doing, it's been
tech entrepreneurs so far.
Next week we have
Tim Armstrong's gonna do one.
Gonna interview Sheryl Sandberg.
- [Gary] That's awesome.
- [Alyson] Yeah, so.
- [Gary] You're legit.
- [Alyson] It's a good group.
- [Gary] Clearly.
It's so funny.
I actually think my kids are
going to have a harder time
being successful than I was.
I think being born in Belarus
coming here with nothing.
My parents working every
minute, that instilled a huge
competitive advantage,
a chip on my shoulder,
a work ethic that I think
there's a very good reason that
in the American
meritocracy system to the,
you know, by comparison.
There's always stuff.
But in capitalism or the version
that we've lived through in the
last 50 years in America,
immigrants win a lot.
I was a very poor student
which was really unusual for
immigrants but I don't
see education as my way out.
I knew that I had it and
that originally started as
I'm a good salesman.
And then it was I'm a good
businessman and then it was
I'm a good operator and now the
current terms is
I'm a good entrepreneur.
So yeah, it's a
DNA thing with me.
Even online dating.
I met my wife on
JDate, right? In 2003.
- [Alyson] I didn't
know it was around in 2003.
- Right. And when it
was super like sacrilege.
- [Alyson] Were
you the only two users?
- No. New York Jewish dating
scene was pretty hoppin' but
I just remember thinking like in
10 years every single person,
I didn't think they'd be swiping
to the right but I'm like every
person's gonna do this
'cause this is practical.
And so, people are romantic.
People are like well I'll never
buy a tomato on the internet.
This is what I heard in '96.
I'm like, "You will."
'Cause time is valuable.
Because other
things matter more.
And so, I knew because I thought
people would buy stuff on the
internet long before
a lot of people thought.
- [Alyson] What is dinner
like with Mark Zuckerberg?
- Well, listen,
this is 2008, '09, '10.
That's the Mark I know.
I knew it.
Like when I tell you I knew it,
I wish I was video
blogging back then.
The first dinner I had,
it was interesting to me.
So I'm built on
emotional intelligence.
I'm not the smartest.
I just know what
people are gonna do.
So he's a tech kid and an
engineer and a Harvard kid
so I go in thinking he's that.
I leave that
dinner I'm like fuck,
this kid absolutely
gets human behavior.
So that's when I knew,
binarily, that he was gonna win.
'Cause I'm like
wow, he's got both.
He know how to build it.
Like I can't build stuff.
I'm not an engineer,
it's not what I'm into.
I'm like but he
understands what I understand.
That was it.
I mean I was just
bought into him from Day One.
He's super smart.
Listen we're a funny match
in the 10 or 15 times we've
interacted 'cause
I only want to talk and
he only wants to listen.
That's why he'll probably end up
with a hell of a lot more money
and be successful but
he's extremely bright.
I like him a lot.
I think he's kind but most of
all he just understands people.
And that's weird because people
look at him as introverted and
quirky and all
that but I don't see it.
And I never saw it.
Obviously, he's more media
trained and grown into himself.
So I can't speak to how he rolls
now 'cause I haven't spent time
with him but I can definitely
tell you there was no confusion
from those initial meetings
for me and I mean none.
- [Alyson] How do you get rid of
friends who are useless to you?
- You know what's funny?
It's not useless, right?
This has been the one that I've
been very hot on talking about
in the world but I've been scared
of because even when you just
said that I was (groans)
this guy's terrible.
- [Alyson] It's a
good provocative headline.
- It is. I think people are
keeping very negative people
around them and if they aspire
to change their situation it's
imperative to audit the seven to
ten people that are around you
and the reason I go
after a friend or a parent,
in the details of
that headline I said hey,
you may have to audit your mom.
And not that I want you to never
talk to your mom again but you
may want to take a step back.
And I've done this for friends
and acquaintances and it's a
very painful eye-opening
experience to realize wait a
minute my dad actually doesn't
want me to be successful because
he's not happy.
And, you know, whether you
call it misery loves company.
And it's not that
parents are bad people,
it's a human trait.
It's just a thing.
So to me the world where it's
much harder to get rid of your
older sister forever, it might
be intriguing to say hey,
I've had this friend who spends
all their time making sure I'm
not going to the next level and
it really came around the fact
of who listens to
you when you complain?
The only groups of people
that will listen to you are the
people that have to,
your core family,
and your other
loser friends. Right?
Like the other people who also
want to complain about their
boss and yeah I thought it was
actually a very good emotional,
not willing to be talked about,
non-politically
correct thing to say.
Maybe if you got rid of one
friend or spent a lot less time
with one friend who's a real
drag and a negative force and
added a positive person in
your office as somebody you now,
if you switched it from 80
days hanging with your negative
friend and 1 day with your
office acquaintance who's super
positive to 4 days with your
negative friend and 12 with this
other person, not
only do I believe,
I've physically watched
me mentor people in my
organizations to a totally
different life on that thesis.
Listen, I don't hide
from being an extrovert.
It comes natural to me.
I can't contain it.
I actually think there's
plenty of negatives that
go along with being out there.
But I think whether, you know I
see a lot of people who come to
me, introverts, "Hey Gary,
I want to be like you.
"I want to be out there."
I'm like why?
And they're like, I'm like,
"You're crushing it being you.
"You need to be more you.
Not a little bit of me."
Self-awareness. I need to run
and we'll do
this again, I promise.
Self-awareness and then reverse
engineer and put yourself in a
position to succeed.
Let's go, Just. We're late.
("Remember Me?" by
Kyle ft. Chance The Rapper)
How are you?
- [Man 3] Good, Gary.
Thank you so much
for doing this, man.
I really appreciate it.
- My pleasure.
I mean you've got
a good sales pitch.
It's only four minutes.
- [Man 3] No worries.
- [Gary] I just can't explain to
everybody clearer when you
figure out who you are
and do all that, you win.
If you're great at painting,
paint and hire a partner
to be your salesperson.
If somebody at 20 years old made
me their business partner as a
painter, they'd be the most
famous painter in the world.
Yet, most painters want to be
the salesman and
businessman and
women as well as the
painter and there's a problem.
85% of painting, 90% of people
that are great at painting are
artists and don't have the
DNA to sell and vice versa.
All my sales friends and
business friends that want to
start all these businesses
around something creative,
I have bad news for you, Joel.
You know, you could
be a great salesman but
your pottery sucks shit.
And so that's that.
That's a very funny
analogy for the following.
Figure out who you are, don't
apologize for who you are and
then become even greater than
you naturally
are at what you are.
- [Man 3] I think too many
people give a shit what other
people think of them as well.
- The whole game's broken
because everybody's too tied up
into other people's opinions.
I only care about
my opinion of myself.
And I care what my mom and wife
and kids and the world think,
just not as much as I care
about the way I think myself.
And that's it.
Just that slight advantage and I
think most of you care more what
other people think than what you
think about yourself and/or
you actually don't feel
good about yourself, right?
The thing that made me smile,
when you just introduced me you
said I'm one of the most
motivational people in the
world, and everybody
I know that's met him
said he's the nicest guy.
There's no comparison to the
better feeling that people that
have actually gotten to know
me say that versus millions,
hundreds of thousands,
tens of thousands
thinking I'm the coolest.
And that's it.
I mean, that's it.
And that's why it's easy for
me to feel good about myself.
Right?
And so, I think a lot of people
need to start with themselves.
Maybe the reason they don't have
more confidence in themselves or
care about their opinion about
themselves versus others is
'cause they know they're
doing things they don't like.
So they need to work on that.
I get offered and
emailed 5,000 different
requests for podcasts
and shows and what
I think my friend here,
let's see his name, Evan.
Beau, I'm sorry.
Evan Carmichael
introduced me to Beau.
What Beau has figured out is
time is the asset and so if you
want Kevin Hart or The Rock or
Beyonce or Ja Rule
or Richard Branson
or Tony Hsieh or
Sheryl Sandberg on your podcast
maybe you should start
the 120 second podcast.
And then you got to be creative
and try to figure out how you
get, maybe you create
the one question video show.
That's it. The whole
show's one question.
Promise you, a lot of people you
want as guests if they see in
the headline, I just need four
minutes of your time for the one
question show, a lot more are
gonna say yes than can you be on
my podcast for
an hour and a half.
What's going on
with this shit traffic?
- [Avi] I know,
we got 15 minutes.
("Remember Me?" by
Kyle ft. Chance The Rapper)
- [Man 4] You live?
- We're live-ish.
Ish.
Hi, how are you?
Yeah, that'd be great.
Thank you. How are you?
- Hey.
- [Gary] Such a pleasure.
- [Amanda] Nice to see you.
So I'm a traditional
television producer and
I'm dying to get into digital.
I feel like it's
time to shake it up,
go for something
I don't really know.
I'm kind of ready
to take the risk--
- And see what's
happening in the world?
- [Amanda] To
see what's happening.
- Yeah.
- [Amanda] So I was wondering
if you looked at my resume.
- I haven't but that's--
- [Amanda] I have
it with me if you want.
- Talk it through, give me,
I'm more audio anyway.
- [Amanda] Okay.
- [Gary] Context it up for me.
Hulu and Amazon and
Netflix are the preview.
There'll be more players.
- [Amanda] Right.
- I mean I'm
gonna be on Apple's,
one of Apple's
new original shows.
There's a lot going on.
- [Amanda] Yeah.
- I actually think this is
very similar to publishing.
- [Amanda] Mhmmm.
- Remember like eight, nine
years ago everyone's like if
I'm a newspaper
journalist, I'm dead.
- [Amanda] Yeah.
- You're not dead, you're just
gonna work at different places.
- [Amanda] Right.
- So, I think you
could fit anywhere.
I think the bigger thing
that I can help you with is not
necessarily anything other than
four to five to
seven people to meet.
- [Amanda] Yeah.
- That can give
you the speeding up.
I mean I think the one thing
you'll have to kind of wrap your
head around is I don't know
how fluffy or comfortable the
budgets of the traditional TV
world were or are or
the people you've worked with.
I think that's usually
the biggest thing that people
struggle with when there's a
landscape change is that usually
when there's a big landscape
change which is absolutely going
to happen with television.
- [Amanda] Yeah.
- You're coming from an end
of an era which means it's the
fattest and kind
of most manifested
of the overhead
that it takes to do it.
And then you go
into the new world.
And then the new
world becomes the old world.
- [Amanda] Right, right.
- You know?
Cable when it was
first produced was--
- [Amanda] Right, yeah.
- You know.
Let me give you a
really good piece of advice.
If you are not on Snapchat,
you should get on.
- [Amanda] Okay.
- And you should,
you're not on it?
- [Amanda] I'm not on it.
- Good.
Let me show you
something that I want you,
that's very important to the
15 year part of your career.
- Okay.
- Maybe not
tomorrow but definitely
in 36 months this
world is very real.
Which is, you're not
gonna understand this,
Snapchat's the
hardest to understand.
- I know. I've heard
it's pretty hard.
- But then you're gonna
Google how do I use Snapchat?
- Yeah.
- You're gonna download it
and in a day you'll get it.
- Yeah.
- There's a part
where they call discovery
where their media is done.
- Yeah.
- In here you
have to see how
Bazaar is producing.
You have to see what's
happening both in video--
- Gotcha.
- and audio form because this
is where the world's going.
- Yeah.
- You have to understand this.
- Have to understand that, yeah.
- If you don't, you're basically
making radio content
for the television.
- Right, right, right.
Thanks.
- [Gary] Such a pleasure.
- [Amanda] You too.
- Yeah, have a great day.
("Remember Me?" by
Kyle ft. Chance The Rapper)
(crosstalk)
Maximize our time, yeah.
- Good afternoon, Gary.
- Good afternoon.
How are you?
- [Man 4] Good, good.
- Good to see ya.
How are you?
- How are you, buddy?
Big day.
- Big day for us.
Let me know if you can make it.
What?
Why are you able to
get me the new episode
so quick and
DRock takes so long?
Could be a quality thing.
Maybe DRock's are really good
and yours are like mailed in.
- You to hold your passport
like that and take a photo.
I think Tyler has your passport.
- Is that true?
To prove who I am or whatever?
- [Sid] Yeah.
It's basically
how they get verified.
- Got it, okay.
- Trying to get you
verified on (inaudible).
Verified on Weibo so you can
make IG story-like
stuff on Weibo.
- I sent you and Tyler an email.
- Yep. Got it.
- Got it.
- [Gary on phone] You will win
but you are upset that somebody
else's grandpappy
got them ahead of you,
then you're gonna lose.
Everybody started ahead of me.
I'm just catching up.
- (chuckles) That's the best.
- [Tyler] Share Bear's
the best thing ever.
- [Man 5] So essentially a
question of really going to be
related to Jerome.
- Perfect.
- [Man 5] How'd you meet?
- Yeah, I'm ready.
I'm ready. I don't
need to know anything.
I'm ready to go.
I was speaking in Toronto in a
conference and went to Q&amp;A and
Jerome raised his hand and
said, "If I beat you in rock,
"paper, scissors can
I come to New York and
"have coffee with you?"
And I said, "Sure."
Came on stage, he beat
me in rock, paper, scissors.
I met him in New York.
Couple of months later he comes
to New York for
a 10 minute coffee.
I was hoping to get out
of there in eight minutes.
Two hours later, I'm asking
Jerome to come with me to
Los Angeles two days later to
spend some time with me.
What ended up happening was
Jerome started talking about
what he believed
was happening on Vine
and with Vine influencers.
I had lived through that
with YouTube and Twitter.
I believed him and we decided
literally that night to start a
partnership around this amazing
world of influencers on Vine.
- [Man 5] And that story
that he has that he was kind of
homeless, super hard in
New York and things like that.
In fact he met you very quickly.
- He met me right away but to
his credit it was very hard.
He lived in, he literally
slept in our office.
You know our business
didn't have any money yet.
And he wasn't making money from
brands so Jerome's
struggle was real.
Yes, he met me and yes I had a
business and I could've paid him
more but he wanted to earn on
his own merit and we're building
a business together and
so he kept it very humble
and he grinded.
And there was many nights that
people would email me and say
there's a man
sleeping in our office.
That was Jerome Jarre.
We're in New York City
at VaynerMedia headquarters.
750 employees here and we're a
advertising agency that focuses
on social media
and digital media.
Your welcome.
("Really? Yeah!" by Kyle)
No, let me show you around.
30 days, in 30 days or
so 30 minutes with him
and his two boys, alright?
Right, how do you amplify?
Let's have a meeting.
I know what to do.
Love ya, good to see ya.
Good to see ya.
Smell good, bro.
Old friends, fun.
Life is good, man. Busy.
I am, I don't know, you tell me.
To be very frank, this
is probably ends up being
a huge win.
I'm committed to whatever it
takes to make everybody feel
delicious on your end.
That's number one
and then, number two,
it will then force a
conversation on two fronts.
One, getting us aligned on
some of these things on Facebook
world where all the action is.
There's so much good happening.
But it also then leads in to
optimizing creative which is
something I want to do a little
bit more of so we'll open up
that can of worms as well.
Yep, I understand.
Cool, alright,
I'm really behind.
I'll start digging even further.
I love you too.
I'll give you any updates
along the way
before the summit, okay?
Okay, talk to you, bye-bye.
("View From Hollywood" by Kyle)
You know what would be amazing?
A video and then
there's somebody over here,
you're watching
and over here and goes,
"If you see this
and go to this URL,
"we'll give you," what if you
gave away 1,000 something but
only the people that
moved and saw the information.
- [Man 6] Yeah.
- Because then the press picks.
Then everybody goes, "No,
no, you have to turn to get."
Then people will start
understanding the game.
- [Man 6] It's
interesting because--
- That's where you need.
You need a piece of content
that not only brings enormous
awareness that you're the leader
but teaches people what to do.
- [Man 6] I get to watch
a movie on a giant screen.
- [Gary] I got it.
Time to go?
- [Tyler] Yep.
- Okay.
I want to do
another wine dinner ASAP,
like we did the other day.
- [Tyler] Like the smaller ones?
- Yeah, you know
how we did eight people?
- [Tyler] Yeah.
- And there's two people I want.
I want him and I want
Jaclyn (censored) who's in my--
- [Tyler] Yeah.
- Can you email both of them and
see if they're around
in three to four weeks?
Pick a day, cancel something
'cause I feel like I'm locked in
pretty hard so
give me some options.
And let's do another wine.
I'm starting to do
these little wine dinners,
introducing friends.
You just came here,
I think it'd be good for you.
("Keep It Real" by Kyle)
Nice to meet you, man.
You look great.
- I watch all your videos.
You're great, man.
- Thank you.
- (inaudible)
- That's awesome, man.
Thank you.
Real pleasure to meet you.
- Thank you so much
for supporting my music.
- Yes, yes, yes.
I know it.
- That was crazy.
My heart was beating.
I made it, right?
- Yeah, we made it.
We made it. My pleasure.
- My photographer.
- Matt, nice to meet you, man.
Thank you, brother.
Picture, sure.
Thank you.
- [DRock] We need
new audio for a podcast.
- [Gary] Yeah, let me do this.
I'm 30 minutes late. See ya.
Let me give you one
massively good piece of advice,
I will always say no when
I'm being told to do something.
Always, always,
it's how you guys have
how you've not picked up.
You've picked up on
every single thing except.
What's that?
- [Man 7] Can
you lower my salary?
- Yes.
("Keep It Real" by Kyle)
So, we're done.
That was it, right?
That's it?
That's a wrap?